et Arnou de SC qui est avec nous vous
êtes consultant en sécurité vous avez
assuré la sécurité de personnalité et
d'homme politique et votre témoignage et
vos anecdotes vont nous passionner je
sais pas si vous avez vu passer cette
information mais Nicolas Sarkozi a porté
plainte parce qu'il a reçu des menaces
de mort il y a un homme qui a été arrêté
avec son fils d'ailleurs et qui a été
interné en en psychiatrie on s'est
interrogé sur la sécurité des des
personnalités et de nos hommes
politiques comment cette sécurité est
assurée sachant par exemple que les
ministres ont une sécurité à vie un
président de la République il a été une
fois il a une sécurité à Vie tout ça
c'est payé effectivement avec nos impôts
n'est-ce pas de scè tout à
fait c'est ça bah c'est vrai non c'est
aujourd'hui un vrai sujet notamment pour
la Cour des comptes qui épingle le sujet
assez régulièrement c'est que ça un coût
indirect combien ça coûte d'assurer tous
nos tous nos anciens ministres à peu
près vous avez une idée d'un chiffre
chiffre en
tête un ancien ministre
et un chauffeur un officier de sécurité
en PER permanence ah c'est quatre
personnels qui tournent en 7 jours 7
jours pour un seul ministre pour un seul
ministre d'accord un président de la
République c'est comme Nicolas Sarkozy
combien de c'est en fonction de l'état
de la menace c'est en fonction de ce
qu'il a pu gérer comme dossier le
service de sécurité sur le président
Chirac était beaucoup moins important
que sur le président hollandre en dehors
de leur fonction d'accord parce que
est-ce que cette sécurité s'allège avec
les années alors elle s'allège où elle
se renforce en fonction des années mais
aussi de l'évolution de la menace euh si
demain une organisation terroriste
qu'elle soit islamiste d'extrême droite
ou d'extrême gauche menace un ancien
président ou menace une personnalité
politique le dispositif de protection va
évoluer en conséquence on va on va
parler de votre quotidien parce que ça
nous intéresse tous de savoir comment
comment on agit effectivement quand on
prot quand on protège un ancien
président un ancien ministre mais
également des des des personnalités ce
ce système comment ça fonctionne au
quotidien le système de protection d'une
personnalité c'estàdire que vous
l'accompagnez tous les jours vous êtes
dans sa voiture ou comment ça se passe
alors il y a ce qu'on appelle l'officier
de sécurité en charge l'épaule celui qui
est dans le véhicule principal de
l'autorité en fonction du
dimensionnement du dispositif tout ça
change mais la personnalité est prise en
compte de Chezelle le matin jusqu'au
soir d'accord vous l'accompagnez en
permanence on est en permanence avec et
le dispositif est plus ou moins
configuré et important en fonction du
risque qui peut peser vous êtes armé sur
les mission au profit du chef de l'État
ou des personnalités politiques
françaises oui on est armé et
aujourd'hui il y a une évolution
législative assez récente depuis
quelques années on peut être armé pour
d'autres personnes mais c'est toujours
le ministère de l'Intérieur qui définit
l'état de la menace qui va de 1 à 4 et
qui détermine si on a une autorisation
de port d' ou pas d'accord Maxime
comment se mesurent les mesures
préventives quand il y a un président
quand il y a une personnalité politique
qui vient faire une émission de
télévision apparemment avant vous allez
regarder les lieux cartographier
regarder autour alors on va envoyer des
éléments précurseurs non seulement pour
reconnaître l'environnement savoir un
peu quelle est l'ambiance et puis aussi
vérifier la topographie des lieux si un
incident se passe sur le plateau il faut
qu'on soit en capacité de pouvoir
exfiltrer et soustraire la personnalité
de façon immédiate mais vous ça vous est
déjà arrivé est-ce que vous avez est-ce
que dans toute votre carrière et je ne
vous demande ni non ni situation est-ce
que ça vous déjà arrivé d'avoir été
obligé d'intervenir dans une situation
de danger pour protéger une personnalité
oui oui oui dans il y a des situations
de tension notamment sur les bains de
foule quand on a des populations qui
peuvent être hostiles à la personnalité
protégée on ça vous est arrivé ça vous
est arrivé une situation vous avez une
foule qui se jetait sur une personnalité
il y avait une tension et un risque
d'agression immédiate donc la décision a
été prise sans en informer la
personnalité de mettre en place la
procédure d'exfiltration et de la mettre
en lieu sûr vous avez déjà eu des
antarteurs non euh non j'ai pas été
confronté à ça mais euh ça arrive
souvent mais c'est il y a eu ce fameux
antarterur belge qui écumait les les les
les plateaux et c'était une menace qu'on
prenait forcément en compte euh parce
que il était plutôt performant Isabelle
et par exemple Jacques shirac sur les
Champs-Élysées en juillet ou euh en 2002
c'est Maxime Brunery qui a c'est la
dernière tentative d'attentat sur un
chef d'État français sur le territoire
national là le contexte est un peu
différent étant donné qu'il avait sa
bulle de protection ce qu'on appelle le
premier cercle qui le protégeit il y a
ensuite le second cercle qui fait
l'environnement et le troisème cercle
qui sont les fonctionnaires de police
des CRS est-ce que vous assuriez la
sécurité de Jack shirac puisque vous en
avez parlé à ce moment-là pas du tout
non c'était pas vous comment comment on
l'exfiltre le président de la République
quand on est sur les
Champs-Élysées il y a des véhicules il
est sur le command car qui est un
véhicule militaire c'est la tradition en
tant que chef des armées il doit se
déplacer sur ce véhicule il faut savoir
que vous avez deux gendarmes qui sont à
l'avant un chauffeur et un officier de
sécurité ils sont en tenu
euh d'apparat mais ils sont tout à fait
en capacité d'évacuer dans les véhicules
qui suivent derrière parce que si vous
êtes attentif vous verrez qu'il y a
toute une
suite de véhicule qui est prête à
évacuer le président et à aller à
proximité et alors quand il monent en
goguette comme ils ont tous des vies
sentimental compliqué que ce soit à
scooter que ce soit contre un camion de
laitier une nuit ils sont là ils sont
autonomes ils ont pas de protection ou
ou ils désobéissent alors je vois pas du
alors l'histoire du
scooter je crois que l'histoire du
scooter il av desésobéissant si je sou
souv bien pardon mais Caroline al de
mémoire il était tout seul il était tout
seul exactement il avait un casque mais
il y avait eu desobéissan non il y avait
un officier de sécurité ah bon ah ah oui
oui bien sûr on sait même qui c'est ou
ah bon non ben écoutez
on de sécurité qui est très différent
par exemple aux États-Unis c'est le
Secret Service le service de protection
du président qui impose au président
tous les protocole c'est-à-dire que le
président américain est euh sous tutelle
de son service de protection alors qu'en
France il peut pas dire non même s'il a
des rendez-vous secrets ça s'organise ah
bon d'accord donc il y a rien de
spontané question de concilier la
sécurité et le désir d'intimité de vie
privée et la vie privée parce que ce
sont des gens qui sont exposés en
permanence oui mais enfin vous les
bordez pas vous les mettez pas dans le
litf vous êtes devant leur porte alors
moi personnellement je nai border
personn quandbord c'est ça le truc mais
on est là pour la sécurisé en permanence
on fait partie de leur vie on rentre
forcément dans leur Intim vousz signer
j'imagine une clause de façon de
confidentialité et cetera on est tenu au
secret profession est-ce que vous avez
le droit de leur remonter les bretelles
parce que c'est quand même nos élus et
ils sont supposés nous représentés les
services américains sont tout à fait en
capacité de remonter les bretelles
personnalité qu'il protège mais les
services français c'est eux qui vous
intéressent est-ce que vous avez
remontter les bretelles d'e personnalité
de sécurité français va remonter les
bretelles à la personnalité qu' protège
mais na jamais de de motif pour le faire
bien évidemment bon Arnaud deè est-ce
que vous avez dû tirer les oreilles
d'une personnalité politique on vous
demandera pas le nom est-ce que ça vous
est arrivé de vous retrouver dans une
situation vous dites STOP oui on prend
des risques ah ah alors là vous
réfléchissez à ce que vous allez me dire
pour des risques pour des risques lié à
leur sécurité oui euh mais pas pour des
risques liés à leur intimité il y en a
qui ont déjà échappé à votre
surveillance de façon intentionnelle
justement il y en a contenté ouais ah
oui il sont pas arrivéss sont pas
arrivés n deè est très très fort
d'accord il le président Macron pour
aller voir un peu la foule lors de
déplacement et parfois c'est pas du tout
prévu au départ ouais ouais ah oui oui
oui ça mais ça effectivement un
président quand il décide de faire des B
fou mais jacirac c'était pareil c'est la
différence avec avec les présidents
américains les présidents américains
appliquent vraiment le protocole défini
par le Secret Service euh les gens qui
du groupe de sécurité de protection de
la présidence de la République eux
doivent s'adapter en permanence à ce que
va faire le président HM et c'est la
même chose pour les ministres bon alors
vous avez une histoire à nous raconter
vous avez aussi assuré la sécurité de
stars de grandes stars je vous laisse
nous dire de de qui vous êtes retrouvé
aussi dans des situations là c'est pas
effectivement une menace de de de mort
mais c'est plutôt des fans qu'il faut
arriver à gérer alors c'était Michael
Jackson euh et on s'est retrouvé
plusieurs fois à avoir des jeunes femmes
qui nous poursuivait euh quand on était
en véhicule en se déshabillant ah en
déabillant bon ça va c'est pas pas de
danger de mort il y avait pas de danger
de mort les Paparadis aussi à gérer qui
sont parfois qui prennent beaucoup de
risque on l'a vu dans le dossier de
l'affaire Lady
Diana
on les gens qui nous demandent de faire
passer des documents des numéros de
téléphone à la personnalité et alors
est-ce que vous les faites passer ça ça
nous intéresse ça vous faites passer les
petits papiers non pas du tout numéos de
téléphone pass non mais c'est pas du
tout notre rôle nous on est là pour
assurer la protection même pas un joli
bouquet de fleurs bah oui c'est sympa ça
non là c'est tout à fait différent on
REM ça au protocole ok ça peut être très
compliqué moi je me suis retrouvé en
vacances avec enfin il y avait Michael
Jordan bon et alors il a un service de
de sécurité énorme mais dans un hôtel où
il y avait pas grand monde donc je me
suis dit tiens je vais aller jouer un
peu au basket devant lui au histoire de
voir comment ça se passe et en fait il y
a un tel service de et ça rigole pas aux
États-Unis he les mecs ils ont un
protocole de fou et je suis allée voir
le chef de la sécurité je lui dis une
petite paire de basket comme ça signé et
tout ça mange pas de pain et c'est niet
et c'est comme ça et ça dérange pas quoi
il a voilà il y a vraiment un cadre
trouvé qu'elle poussa le ballon un peu
loin voilà c'est ça pas mal pas mal
Isabelle pas mal pas mal pas
mal pas mal effectivement personnalité
aujourd'hui vous vous avez laissé ça de
côté vous faites autre chose consultant
en sécurité vous aidez à protéger
aujourd'hui je supervise des dispositifs
de protection de personnalité menacé ah
menacé d'accord mais vous le savez donc
elles sont menacées elles font appel
elles font appel à vous qui qui appelle
à vous on vous appelle on dit allô
AR français ou ou étrangère euh qui font
appel à nos services pour assurer leur
leur sécurité mais comment on vous
appelle comment ça se passe ça peut être
des industriels ça peut être des hommes
politiques étrangers ou notamment j'ai
assuré pendant plusieurs années la
protection d'un avocat qui était menacé
lui très directement et clairement par
les services russes ça coûte cher de
protéger uneou bien sûr que ça coûte
cher combien une fourchette par jour
quel est le prix de la vie voilà ça
c'est c'est vrai personnalité politique
effectivement enfin les les ministres
les présidents c'est nous qui payons ça
c'est une chose pour les privés
effectivement c'est c'est autre chose
donc je veux repose ma question comment
on fait pour faire appel à vos
services benah on m'appelle ouis ouais
on vous appelle vous laissez votre
numéro et on l'inscrit sur
le vous allez voir la
télé voilà c'est ça les gens qui veulent
vous trouver savent comment faire c'est
un petit milieu on est très peu de
d'experts dans le domaine euh à être
reconnu et
donc moi j'ai pas de démarche
commerciale en fait c'est les gens qui
me recommandent ma meilleure publicité
c'est mes clients AR une toute dernière
chose avant de de vous libérer comment
vous en êtes arrivé à faire ce métier là
vous parce que là vous êtes vous êtes
combien à faire ce ce métié comment vous
avez fait il y a par qu'il y a pas de
formation pour ben si il y a les
formations dispensé au fonctionnaires de
police et au militaires de la
gendarmerie dans l'armée moi je suis
ancien militaire et je suis rou trouv en
quittant l'armée on m'a proposé de
protéger un chef d'État étranger fait
des arts martiaux et tout des trucs
genre avec des ça c'est un peu
l'imageal on doit forcément être mais
vous faites genre du truc du CRAV Maga
des trucs comme ça non ce qu'on appelle
la maîtrise sans armes de l'adversaire
du MS voilà vous avez déjà eu peur
pardon non non ben la peur est naturelle
quelqu'un qui n'a pas peur c'est
quelqu'un qui psychiquement non mais
c'est quelqu'un qui psychiquement n'est
pas totalement équilibré si vous avez
pas de peur vous n'avez pas de
discernement euh et oui oui bien sûr il
y a il y a eu des des missions notamment
à l'étranger en en Afghanistan en Libye
où forcément ben vous avez peur vous
avez des monté d'adrénaline et c'est
aussi ce qui fait un peu le charme de
notre métier quoi merci beaucoup ARN de
scè en tout cas c'était c'était
passionnant